today's topic
thank you igor for that sublime
performance i feel like
i'm in a virtual heaven
hey man if sublime heaven means cutting
yourself then congratulations
and now let's mingle and jingle with the
stand-up comedian who taught us
on netflix that f is for family
who writes these what's her little ad
libs in the middle
it's so awkward he's nominated for his
first grammy this year in the best
comedy album category
ladies and gentlemen here's bill bill
burr whoa this is the first
oh this is so cringy bro maybe it's
because you're not you don't hear the
claps in between so you just have the
awkward silence afterward but she went
oh my god now i know why the grammy
ratings were so low this year i never
watch it anyways but
let's see what all this drama is about
okay thank you janae how are you
was i the only one who wanted to kill
himself during that piano solo
[ __ ] you guessed it you was right
that's right man
that was hella depressing especially
during pandemic can we be a little bit
more uplifting but whatever what do i
care
i bought a suit for this i thought it
was gonna be on tv i'm such a [ __ ]
i am losing so much money right now all
right shout out to all the rock stars
that i wanted to meet tonight who are
watching at home instead i'm talking to
you don dawkin
all right what i'm old that was my first
concert
all right here are the next categories
up for bits for best latin
[Music]
all right uh and the winner uh the
grammy goes to
natalia la for que di
[Music]
oh sorry i will accept on behalf of her
if i butcher the name i'm sorry
all right hey how many uh feminists are
like going nuts
why is this this white male doing all
this latino stuff
that drove people wild so people went
bonkers after that and they're like yeah
why is a straight what's this white male
which is funny because he's aware and
he's laughing about it but go ahead
you're mad yet again at bilber being
bill burr
i mean and you know just to bring
another point and this pandemic thing
all right all the people that are mad
about this and mad about bill bird
whatever what not
um do not host they do not do anything
like that
of the sort i'm talking about most of
the people that are mad and hosting is
something that is very difficult me
being an host
not only that in the pandemic thing i've
hosted the
events independent it's not it's not
great
you cannot feed off the energy of the
people in the room you cannot do
anything like that so you're really on
your own you see how the first one
those jokes were bad and everything and
stuff i'm not even gonna be mad about
that
that's really because of there's no
there's nothing to
fill the void that that that's happening
sometimes you think
a big organization is often well put up
together
but sometimes it's not maybe they didn't
have some i don't know that but
you're mad that's what makes you mad
it's like you want to cancel you wanted
to cancel billboard for the longest time
that you're like oh you know what let's
jump on every occasion
if this one's going to be the one is
this one's going to be the one is this
one's going to be
no it's not in two days we're not going
to be talking about this and
neither is you so the people that don't
like the bill burr
we're not meant to like bilber and the
people that do like him don't care those
who matter don't care those who care
don't matter
yeah man can't cancel living legend
that's how i feel about it bilber's done
this thing for so long
he's one of the best at it and uh you
know people are like well just because
he has a black wife doesn't mean he
doesn't like
bruh what does that happen you guys are
reaching for straws so badly
anytime a straight white male like
imagine like straightness being like the
bane of everyone's existence like this
is so cringy to me this whole discussion
this whole dialogue is so cringy and
outdated but
i honestly don't know how relevant it is
i i don't know i'm not on twitter enough
to really feel it hey guys be sure to
like comment and subscribe if you're
enjoying today's video
we're going to be coming back to you
guys five to six times a week including
live streams
so i mean yo just like the videos help
us out with the algorithm the more we
grow
the more we can make for you the more
you can spend time watching abbott
preach you know what i mean and i don't
know if twitter is really real life i
don't think most people care
no this is a non-issue to me it's not a
family oh my god
shut up somebody's funny nobody cares
why can't he pronounce the names why did
they hire him to pronounce names they
know he can't say
that's the grammy's fault it is what it
is i mean if i book you to do a job and
you got to spell a bunch of arabic names
and you can't do it well it is what it
is
they should have prepared beforehand
they should have had cues like that's on
them
butchering names is unacceptable bro
some of them foreign ass names is hella
hard to say they should have gotten
foreign people to say them names because
that's
not easy and you should know you're a
foreign yeah yeah
yeah aba abba with one b or two b's
is it ava yeah y'all be [ __ ] up basic
names we keep on saying the name you
know what pisses me off the most what
most of the people writing to us is like
yeah what's up alvin preach you're
[ __ ] up the name
and the name is the title of who you're
texting you're [ __ ] up the name
it's right there that's how it be
sometimes no it ha
that's not with two b's sometimes what i
did there
that's what they did this whole thing is
a non-issue people just they love to
complain about stuff
and they're always like oh white man
shouldn't speak and i was just like bro
this is so
boring because nobody cares i'm a person
of color we're marginalized so
when white men speak it just bothers me
shut up on a night where like
so many minorities won it was it making
the stallion one beyonce broke records
broke records you know what i mean it's
just like kevin on a night seven one
okay what do you win kevin kitchenada oh
yeah
two grammys that's the guy from around
the way
we know kevin well i know kevin on the
night with so much of that just for you
guys to just be crying about this it's
just so redundant i'm bored
that's how i feel about it so maybe
maybe i'm wrong about this whole thing
but
no people are just so sensitive nowadays
it's like whatever that's my thoughts on
the topic
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below did you guys feel like
bill burr's uh
comments were probably not acceptable
he's problematic
you're just giving him more material for
another special hey man listen
hey man listen if these people get their
way they're gonna kill comments you ever
heard safe space comedy of course
it's a black guy and a woman and a trans
woman
walk inside a bar and everything was
nice because everybody's equal thank you
very much
foreign